my name is Brant Delgado  and I am the inventor of the Irby is an  all-electric vehicle there's no pedaling  involved and it has a range of about 20  miles and will go about 15 mile an hour  for its top speed one of the things that  I wanted to design into the Irby was the  ability for it to fold up incredibly  small so you can keep it with you on a  train or a bus when you get off the  train just simply open it up it takes  about a half a second for it to become  an actual vehicle the whole thing weighs  just under 30 pounds came up with the  idea for the ER be based on the need for  people to have a vehicle to get to and  from work if they choose to take public  transportation it's called the last mile  scenario it's different than a bicycle  because it is a short wheelbase and it  lives are very small and your feet are  actually connected to the steering on  the front deal but it really isn't  difficult to ride and typically most  people will go maybe a few feet and  they'll get it